les rumeurs n'ont toujours pas disparu j'en ai
appris plus sur l'humiliation au
cours des dernières semaines et j'espérais que dans une
vie tu épouserais l'esprit sauvage
essayant d'apprivoiser ses voisins
j'ai été reine à peine dix ans à cette
époque je  'ai eu trois Premiers ministres pas
un n'a duré le cours
Je comprends la démission du Premier ministre
et pas seulement le Premier
ministre et ta maman ta sœur et ton
pays l'acharnement de tout ça
[ __ ] ensemble arrête arrête une minute
mais n'est-il pas possible qu'il y ait  pas d'
autres problèmes il y a certains d'entre nous qui
sont fu peu importe quelle famille
[Musique]
vous